okay yeah fingers crossed be on skype
and phone okay yep bye it's a big day at
estic the european space agency's
research and Technology Center on the
Dutch coast the scientists here are
testing whether they can move a robotic
arm via a mobile communications network
it's being controlled by a colleague 500
kilometers away the goal is to one day
be able to do the same over distances of
millions of kilometers directing robots
on faraway planets from the surface of
the earth we actually want to bring
people to mmoss the next mission to Mars
is slated for 2016 with current
technology our planetary neighbor is too
far away for astronauts to make the trip
but a robot could make it easily there
are still hurdles to overcome until the
mission lifts off NASA dropped out of
the project not long ago and the ESA is
now working together with the Russian
space agency Roscosmos to make it happen
since the beginning of the political
crisis in Ukraine relations have grown
strained and the Russians are supposed
to supply both cash and the launch
vehicle they are very important clearly
nobody's are replaceable but then it's
like if you were to to go on a trip and
sharing the cost the other one drops out
now you share with yourself so does a
financially
the experts tinker with the Mars rover
in a realistic Martian landscape set up
right next door to the robotics lab once
the vehicle is out on its own on the
surface of the red planet problems like
this would be disastrous their wheels
too stuck in the terrain you run into
trouble there are still many small
problems to iron out with the vehicle
here on earth and more than a few big
ones what are the researchers looking
for exactly the goal is to
scientifically to search for traces of
life and the best place to look for
traces of life is in the subsurface in
the top let's say meter 22 metres
underground but just how much will it
cost to find that out the european space
researchers are constantly developing
new high-tech tools for example this
space simulator it's for testing
electronic components that one day might
be used in the Mars mission how well did
the parts withstand the vacuum radiation
and extreme temperature fluctuations in
space the project is swallowed more than
a billion euros so far more than twice
its original budget the investment we do
its investment in the future and it's
certainly not a major investment we're
talking about basically the equivalent
of one playing one cinema ticket for
every European citizen per year to do
missions like this to discover the first
light of the universe like in plank so
let's share my screen with your screen
so that you can follow back to the
robotic arm experiment the engineers in
darmstadt are trying to install a
component from 500 kilometers away in
noordwijk the arm keeps missing its
target because the signals telling it to
move take a few seconds to arrive have
the engineers bitten off more than they
can chew
when finally success via a wireless
network the arm has performed the
assigned task if it hadn't worked it
would have been pretty embarrassing for
us yeah definitely now the remote
control team can move on to the next
stage of testing controlling the robot
using radio signals after all there is
no cell phone reception on Mars